hi recheck nation I'm Greg Alva and I'm
Renee Arielle Renee Arielle is here give
the middle name is that knowledge oh
really you don't know my last name
oh [ __ ] okay let's keep it at that
mystery is more intriguing anyway we're
you're gonna watch a short film today
called ouch I don't know what this is I
don't know if it's funny or dramatic or
painful or whatever basically here's a
story okay my brother shabby Co a famous
guy in India and other parts of that
region he recommended a few short films
along with a Chara Kirk and this is one
of them and Renee who has been on JV
coach annal I have who do you prefer
look at the camera I'm definitely Hugh
Greg you're my you're my favorite Greg
he's my favorite Greg out of all the
greats that's right
ouch to you javi his videos
greatly surpassed viewcount in terms of
and renee guys if you haven't done so
already follow her on Instagram and
Twitter
you'll like it there she's very
religious and goddammit the trendy the
trendy trendy that's what's gone has a
brand new show go check it out it's an
awesome stuff if you love hearing about
celebrities oh boy you're gonna you're
gonna love this one
yeah 1 2 n
[Music]
fancy oh yeah no idea large short film
does are great short films I saw one
there's no I have not
[Music]
Friday okay already into the music sold
oh my god I think this is gonna be
painful
oh god mr. fancy oh man I like his style
just very early 2000s but this dial I
mean those jeans get cut on his head
yeah
[Music]
the word is [ __ ] in case you guys he's
living the life oh no that's the
suitcase we saw in the little intro
[Music]
she cried I think so maybe she also
wants the yarra video yeah you guys have
no idea you could have an affair 15 I
keep soon disbanded it's like on weird
it's all wrinkles what's happening I
don't know she's gonna pretend
everything's fine though maybe she knows
we need answers now oh they're about to
do something
okay okay I'm kind of totally confused
my dad oh this is this is weird they're
not gonna do it on sweetie couch are
they I don't understand their
relationship yeah I'm sure they'll
explain it but like is she the mistress
is she someone he wants to sleep with I
mean I feel like they've slept together
yeah like that they're very close to
each other but it's also weird like look
squeaky couch that's gonna come to play
no suit other than one that's why he has
the band-aid
he left his woman
I'm rooting for them I guess what day is
it today is it her birthday three years
and he just left his wife yeah I just
really want to do it I guess now that
he's free she doesn't care
yeah
family those unique given Kelly
[Music]
why did you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good even a [ __ ] impossible dream
[Music]
[Music]
Rene has been in this exact situation is
not 15 minutes
what is it the suitcase that's a great
question maybe she's gonna kill him
I love that how she works for it with
him so you're not gonna be friends
oh that is like something Crazy's gonna
have
[Music]
spies shouldn't cheat
oh man
I know hurts to relate sorry what's he
gonna do oh I guess that would be out
Supan our
[Music]
maybe show up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no he's a suitcase squashed on his heart
just like the intro wow that was like I
really got a big fu that hold on he
really deserved it
yeah geez well Rene what did you think
well we let the credits roll in case
there's something in case there's a
post-credits thing where he's just
talking with his mom on the phone yeah
funny
I liked it um I kind of wanted it to be
longer yes I wanted more to happen well
do you still have your dating blog I do
yeah that's right so you know you know
the thing or two about yeah everything
like sexting in the city where I talk
all about dating but never never about
cheaters no not about cheaters no I
honestly think that would be an
interesting blog you've never dated a
guy in like a married man
surprisingly no well I hear I hear
you're missing out very guy kind of
thing man dang that was out you know but
like also he kind of deserved it kind of
he really deserved hmm I like the more
you learn about this guy that's all he
seems like hey I don't want you to cry
Yeah right I want you to think things
that just would never fly with me yeah I
cry and I also think unfortunately guys
so damn I don't know this guy is
something I love that it was a story of
him following through with this whole
like affair like let's be together I
left my wife and then she couldn't do it
and the way she told him was so drawn
out like she wouldn't just tell him as
soon as they got there so just kept
hurting worse he thought his life and or
their life was gonna take off in it it
did not I was pretty impressed by how it
is primarily just them talking like in
the close approximately yeah we're you
and I are just cutting back and forth
it's primarily what it is and it managed
to be very engaging oh yeah do you need
to do any like cool editing or like oh
they're playing with something yeah I
don't know some like scene work thing in
order to make it more interesting it's
just on their performance in their eyes
the music for our American Minds was
maybe just a little bit different yeah
very culturally it's like it's all a
different experience but for me I was
like this music seems like kind of
quirky here more this kind of experience
yeah I felt the same way and I was
thinking is probably just different
difference in culture yeah because that
for me this was a completely different
short film to happen I really overall
very much enjoyed it I was way more into
it than I originally thought I was going
to be just because short films be honest
Oh short films for me aren't really my
thing when there are 20 minutes I always
feel like they're gonna be incomplete
and I know I said it should be longer
yeah but that's because I'm just not a
short film person but honestly I thought
the acting was a great yeah and I really
loved how you just you wanted to know
what the hell she was going to say and
how the suitcase was going to what the
suitcase even was because from the
beginning they tease that in the intro
and then she brought that suitcase and
then she told him she wasn't gonna be
with him so you're like why does she
have a suitcase it's very misleading
yeah I got a question though I mean do
you think she should have told her
husband do you think that you feel like
you should if you have in a pair of
fusion if you've been cheated on do you
feel like you deserve some now yes I
actually got into a whole discussion
about this with your brother because he
does not think they you should
fascinating yeah I think you should tell
because I think it'll eat you up and if
you're gonna even if you don't stay in
the relationship I think you should be
honest I'm a bad liar and I hate holding
on to I wouldn't feel to hold on to the
guilt of it right right yeah I'm right
there with you man if I were her husband
I would want to know and I would think
that she should tell them at some point
yes on the trip with the family in the
car okay yeah yeah when you're already
on the plane that way you have to talk
it out exactly or you could punish by
just being silent and resentful the
tire time yep it was kind of weird to be
like they're both kind of awful what ice
kind of sympathize for their girl a
little bit as opposed to the guy yeah it
was like yeah you kind of deserve the
frying pan you seem like a it always
amazes me because I feel like it's like
that in real life too like the most
[ __ ] guys are the ones who tend to
have like multiple women - oh yeah it's
kind of weird well yeah that's how they
that's why they're okay with doing that
and I feel like when they're both
escaping their lives like what really
got me was that they were both in a
married relationship marriage
relationship doesn't marry but on top of
that the fact that they've been in this
for three years while married like long
time that's so long when she said that
I'm like girl it took you this long to
end it three years I mean they work
together so it makes sense how they
would get away with it like that little
nugget of like okay you guys work
together yeah because there was that
part of me going how would you get away
with this right pretty here's a long
time I mean I've met people who are like
been in long ass relationships with
someone who is married and stuff and
that alone is strenuous I can't imagine
two different many couples yeah man it's
a big story we're LA you've only been in
LA for five years Renee you only you're
gonna see so many people dating married
people out here it's nuts man it's an
ugly situation but it really exists all
right
well comment below if you're dating
someone who's married or if you're
currently cheating on your spouse would
love to know your thoughts and opinions
on this short film Thank You Renee for
being here you guys can follow her on
social media
go check out her trendy and I go check
her out over there also subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
belt and don't cheat on your significant
others or else or else Renee's coming